دبلوماسي فاشل هكذا هجمت احدى ابرز الصحف
الفرنسيه رئيس البلاد ايمانويل ماكرون عقب
تصريحات اثارت جدلا داخليا وخارجيا صحيفه
ليباراسيون وصفت محاوله ماكرون للدفاع عن
الاستقلال الاستراتيجي الاوروبي بالخرقاء
وذهبت الى ان الرئيس يبدو راضيا عن بكين
في الملف التايواني ماكرون رفض في تصريحات
له
لصحيفتيكو الامريكيه وصحيفه ليزيكول
الفرنسيه عقب زيارته للصين اي تبعيه
للولايات المتحده او الصين حول تايوان
الرئيس الفرنسي اعاد وجدد موقفه بعد ايام
من هولندا
اصر على دوري الاستقلاليه الاستراتيجيه ان
تكون حليفا ليس معناه ان تكون تابعا
ماكرون اكد ايضا على ضروره تقليل الاعتماد
على واشنطن لا سيما في مجال الامن وصناعه
العسكريه والدولار ايضا
نبره مكرونيه حاده تجاه واشنطن استقبلها
مسؤولون امريكيون لغه دبلوماسيه غير ان
اصواتا لم تتردد في انتقاد موقف ماكرون
دونالد ترامب مثلا حاضر
لدينا هذا العالم المجنون الذي ينفجر في
كل مكان والولايات المتحده ليس لها راي
على الاطلاق قلت لنفسي حسنا ماكرون كان
صديقا لي ورايته يلاحق ويزور بكين ماكرون
ابدا سفه لما بدا من الترامب واعتبر ان
ذلك يساعد الموقف الرئاسه الفرنسيه اشارت
الى ان ترامب اول من التمس العذره للصين
حين كان رئيسا لكن ذلك لم يمنع من انتقاد
ماكرون صحيفه
وصفت موقفه بالفشل كذلك صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز اعتبرت الزياره تقويضا للجهود
الامريكيه الراميه لاحتوائ نفوذ النظام
الاستبدادي بقياده الرئيس الصيني على حد
قولها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات